然后今天呢
我们会尽量把跟这些实时的阴影相关
的话题给说完啊
这么个意思
那么还是一样呃
在课程正式开始之前
我们先说一个事儿
什么呢
就是我们的作业一
我们作业一
我们的助教同学们正在积极的筹备中
然后还需要一点点时间
请大家稍微耐心一点
好吧啊
然后呃尽量今天国内的今天可以呃
呃可以发布
如果不行的话
那就是明天了
好吧啊
然后正常情况下呢
我们这几次作业
应该每一次作业都有1.5个星期
就按十天来算吧
差不多是有那么长时间可以做的
应该是没有问题的好吧
那么作业一虽然还没有发布
但这里已经有一位大佬同学已经哈哈哈呃
这自己把它给实现出来了
我的天
这实在是非常夸张的一件事情啊
啊我们这个好好表扬一下maxwell同学
听一下这名字
max思维就非常厉害对吧
ok啊大佬工业界大佬啊
非常厉害
然后大家看这个渲染的效果非常的好啊
然后大家可以看到这些阴影对吧
特别是202酱的手投影出来的这个阴影
这是很明显的软阴影对吧
然后呢
右边我和我一位朋友来聊着这样一个结果
然后他告诉我说
他以为这是这是照片
他以为这是我新买的手办
他觉得这个做得非常和谐
然后说我这个呃教教实时的
这做的已经非常像离线了啊
非常好
然后说这位确实是大了
那么这是谁评论的呢
那当然这是另一位大佬
这就是传说中的文刀秋二
哈哈这是edward流啊啊dlss的创始人之一吧
啊nvidia的超级大佬啊
大家可以看到啊
他都对这么一个结果做出了这么高的评价啊
非常好啊
提出表扬是这样啊
我这正好趁这个事情我多多说一句
多说一句什么呢
然后我知道max well大佬是在在工业界的
然后就是工业界
大家可以从这幅图就可以看到
有着极其强大的工程知识动手能力
对不对
然后呢呃学术界这边呢
当然大家之后再上这门课
或者是反正对学术界的正常理解吧
完整的知识体系与解决新问题
甚至发现新问题的研究能力
那会是一个非常相得益彰的事情啊
这更进一步印证的说确实没有问题啊
然后咱们这个课上把这个科学给说清楚
然后技术上大家可以继续呃
然后把这个呃之后的技术都给锻炼好啊
非常好好的
那这就是咱们这课前表扬
ok那么这节课呢啊
我原本说我砍掉了一些内容哈
但这一次呃突然今天发生了一些意外的事件啊
然后导致说我们这节课呢
有很多东西需要跟大家去讨论
那是什么事儿呢
唉这里大家可以猜一猜对吧哈
好吧啊
不过没关系吧
我来说啊是这么回事
正常情况下呢
呃作为图形学上这所谓最高级别的会议哈
大家都知道叫srah ciraph的投稿时间是1月底
然后出review的时间是3月初
然后出结果的时间是3月底
那么今天正好赶上他出结果
然后呢
我呃之前上个月这个时候就已经坐不住了
我想着哎review要出了嘛
然后我就觉得非常的这个坐立不安
于是我就去看节目啊
看各种各样的节目
于是我就去看了星际的一场比赛
大家可以看到这是马路对solar的比赛
然后如果有同学看过的话呢
哈哈哈大家就会发现啊
为什么呢
是因为在这场比赛中
老仙又发功了哈哈
然后他再这幅截图的前一秒说了六个字
不可能中的呀哈哈
然后大家的下一秒就可以看到这个sa的大部队
被马入的原子弹给打中了
诶好吧
于是呢诶当时呃我这看了之后
我觉得好嗯嗯这回sirrah应该是稳了
因为他说不可能中的
对不对
所以呢今天得到了好消息
那么那么在这次的craft中
就我和合作伙伴嘛
然后总共有四篇paper被收录到siggraph 2021中
好吧嗯然后这里特别感谢呃
我的是全明星的同学们和合作伙伴们啊
非常感谢大家
然后呢呃作为四篇paper的话
在渲染领域哈
今年很有可能就是今年siggraph最多的paper了
因为每1年siggraph渲染的paper非常少嘛
十篇出头吧
然后如果有四篇的话
那应该是呃最多了好吧
然后呢由于这四篇siggraph呃中了
然后这同时造成了一个事情
那就是我的职业生涯中cirh呃
这个期刊啊
这些都是就是最顶级的了啊
加起来论文已经达到了20篇啊
然后这是一个非常里程碑的一件事情啊
是这样啊
就是说啊咱们的不同领域不应该呢过去呃
各种各样的去比较啊
甚至子领域
就是说大家平常很难见到
说我去跟比如说什么呃simulation啊
或者是做几何的呀
就是都是空军学内部
咱们说谁siggraph paper多
因为这个领域是相差的特别多
那么20篇呃rendering的paper
那算是非常多了
呃到一个什么程度了呢
但我觉得吧如果我现在跟我的系主任说
我要退休
应该是可以的啊
这个意思好吧
嗯然后差不多是这么个意思啊
这就是说一下啊
炫耀一下
当然我今天非常高兴
然后我才会这么说
大家知道我平常还是店里稍微低调一点啊
这个意思行吧
嗯然后呢嗯借这个机会呢跟大家说一说
这这这这个事儿对吧
就是关于siggraph嗯
大家有同学会说我不是已经有很多的paper了吗
干嘛还要发那么多paper呢
那这里是一个我很想跟大家探讨的一个问题
好吧
那这这怎么说呢
就是说学术上大家平常都会关注一个啊
这个所谓数量跟质量
就是多还是基因这么一个呃权衡嘛
这么个意思就是说有不同的啊组研究的组
不同的人不同的方向啊
大家都选择了不同的这些这些啊
这些嗯怎么说呢
方式去推动他们各自的这些科研
我自己当然也是这样
不过呢咱们从第一节课啊
咱们从这门课的第一节课
应该跟大家说了一下这个事儿对吧啊
嗯什么呢
就是说呃实时现场对吧
我们要做到什么呢
我们要做到高质量
我们也希望他能够能够快
我们不希望权衡
我们希望我全都要对吗
那么在这个啊科研很少
唉我其实胃口是非常大的对吧
就是说我是希望说又可以有多的paper
又可以把他们都给做得好
那这当然是目标了
是这么个意思
那么为什么我一定要这么做呢
这其实是一个很心酸的一个背后的一件事情呢
啊那么这这这这啊说来是这样哈
就是说我在博士毕业的时候
然后当时呢我人还在berkeley啊
我和berkeley的任ng老师啊
大家还记得他对吧
说了他好多次了
呃
和他探讨过很多
这些我要怎么样找工作的这么一个事情啊
就是在学术界转一圈
我应该怎么样去好好去面试啊
或者干什么
然后呢他当时跟我说一个事情啊
当时算是第一个人跟我呃好好说的这么一个啊
一定是需要注意的一个事情啊
很有哲理的一个事情
什么呢
原话我不记得了
但是我可以简单说一下
嗯大概是这么个意思啊
lji you're not just going to sell yourself
as a superstar
you're also going to sell the sports
ok大家能听得明白这个意思吧
就是说你如果去找工作
你要做的事情不只是说把自己给推出去
作为一个超级巨星这么一个意思哈
你还得把你所做的这项工作也得把它给说出去
让别人能够接受
言下之意
就是大家都知道rendering这个领域是非常难的
它难在很多不同的方面
它难在首先idea非常的难想
很多人就会说rendering呢这个领域大概做不动了
这么个意思
很多的这些这些想法呢都之前都被解决掉了
或者是剩下来的都是很难的想法
那么我的一个嗯嗯感觉就是什么呢
一方面说的是对的
另一方面我不希望承认这个事情对吧
我有我自己自负的地方
这是没有问题的
ok然后这里呢就是说嗯
嗯就是说不管在呃之前找工作吧
这些所谓cd sport的这么一个工作
所以从这个角度上来说呢
就是说哎确实从发paper的角度上来说
又得发很多的paper
然后呢又得把这些paper的质量给做好
然后这样的话才能为别人所承认
才能让别人认为说
或者说给热爱rendering的同学们
老师们提供一个信号
说rendering还是有东西可以做的
然后我虽不才对吧
但是这是我希望能够带给大家的一件事情好吧
那么哎我之前说我平常没事看一看nba对吧
然后大家知道我最喜欢的球星是谁吗
他是呃就是库里啊
然后就是说哎为什么我喜欢他呢
因为一定程度上有很多东西是挺相似的对吧
大家知道库里呢
他作为一个nba的球星
他是没少啊
这是呵呵很严重的一个事情
然后呢如果他希望联盟能够认可自己的话
他就得投402个三分
他就得过了
中场就顶着人头才会有人承认好吧
所以说一定程度上来说
然后希望能真正能够把rendering作为一个呃
呃非常不错的领域
然后这个嗯嗯带给大家rendering之后
更多的可能性吧
这么个意思好吧
那简单跟大家说一说这背后的一个思想
就是说我又要做多又要做精
这是我一定要做到的事情
好吧好吧嗯就是这么一个事情了啊
ok啊简单说一说
这次因为这个sirh呢
然后想到了一些事跟大家分享一下
大家不只是说从课也要学一些什么
这些基础知识
大家还得意识到说啊
这个呃各行各业工作都不太容易的
对吧啊
ok好嘞
咱们再回到刚才说的事
我说什么来着
我说我这啊
我因为这次sp了
导致说我现在啊论文啊
这个系列的论文啊攒够到了20篇
那攒够了20篇到底有什么好事情呢
大家可以看到这是greater news
greater news是什么呢
就是说我终于把我的ps four赎回来了
诶这是什么意思呢
啊那所以说跟大家简单说一说
我的这个故事啊
这么个意思
就是说呢
然后当时就买了
买了之后呢
哎这没打多少东西
打了些这个美国末日
然后呢打了gta 5
然后就被领导给拿去了
家里领导哈
这这被领导拿去征用了
那这我就没办法了
那就那就给他了
然后我说那我什么时候才能把ps four赎回来呢
那领导就想问一下
领导告诉我说呃
说等你攒够20天cig rap的时候
你就可以把它给赎回来了
然后那么今天就是这么一个历史性的时刻
哈哈我终于把ps four赎回来了好吧
然后我就可以嘿嘿嘿之后可以愉快的玩耍了
这是非常开心的一件一件事情好吧
然后呢那肯定有同学会说这个意思
你为什么不给他买一个chrome cast
或者拿任何什么盒子
是不是这个意思吧对吧
然后呢那这么说的同学
那么非常抱歉
看来你还没意识到你为什么单身
对不对
这领导做出的决定
你都可以质疑是吧
嘿嘿嘿嘿嘿嘿嘿诶好吧好吧好吧嗯
所以说呢就是呃这么个少啊
那么嗯哎呀还我那么那么在这之后呢
我当然还有下一步的目标
下一步的目标是什么呢
也是领导给定好的
定好的是什么呢
就是哎我需要30篇啊
总共啊攒够30篇zoe
我就可以解锁ps 5啊
这是非常开心的一件事情
然后如果顺利的话
看看明年年底能不能完成这个任务
如果不行的话
后年也可以啊
到时候嗯反正不区分pro
到时候也可以买
好吧啊
这么个事儿
到时候看30篇啊
希望能够做到
那么呃跟这个同时还有另外一个上
顺便跟大家说一说
就是说我在家里面
大家可以看到我在games 101里面发了番外对吧
这个games 101做的就是就是就是弹段琴
然后现在再弹一个电子钢琴
然后我觉得我想换一个换一个真的钢琴
我就跟领导商量
哎我跟领导商量呢
那领导领导说那行吧
你要是想换钢琴的话
那你就去你就去把激流给练了
哈哈是吧
然后我我说好啊
这个问题不大
但是我说我想换一个好点琴
我想换一个施坦威的琴
那领导想了想说
那不行
那你就得把李斯特的钟给练好
然后我那行吧
所以说这就变成了我的下一步目标
那那那那我就练着呗
反正这个这个钟它不是一般人练的真的
然后他有个俗名叫我还能大跳
可能大家去随便看一看任何的什么视频
大家就知道为什么会有这么个俗名了
好吧
夸张无比的唉行吧
不知道这跟30篇zh或者说ps 5
什么时候哪一个能够先到了再说吧好吧
反正就是说这是这么个事
ok嗯行吧
那这就是这一个更好的消息
那么是这样哈
就是说我说今天呃就正好借这个机会吧
然后我顺便我一定要做一个广告呃
为什么要这么做呢
唉是因为生活所迫呀
没办法呀
我原本想着说我们找一个什么其他时间啊
或者这课的最后能想着不趁着cirh这波
我顺便把这东西东西都给说完之后
就没什么机会了
对吧啊
哈哈哈哈好吧
然后呢嗯那这要我在说什么呢
我在说这个事儿
就是呃大家都知道了
这正常情况下
不管看电视剧或者干什么
第二季要干什么呢
第二季肯定要用来植入广告
对不对
那所以说我在这个嗯第二节课上
我也植入一下广告
那么呃我是要干什么呢
是这样的哈
就是说啊说句非常现实的一个呃一句话哈
就是说我现在呃这是非常非常缺银子的
那我缺银子是怎么回事
我说清楚
不是我个人缺银子
我说我缺银子
使
是没有这个对应的资金去支持我的博士生们啊
或者说去招更多的博士生们
这么个意思啊
不是个人的
就是说嗯怎么回事呢
就是我被招到这边啊
呃来开始当这个所谓assistant professor之后
到目前为止
这个方定的是哎
就是这资金是非常非常非常呃怎么说呢
不成功的
这已经2年多了
戏里面给的快要被我用完了
然后呢之后再没有更多的资金支持的话
就实在是养不了我的这些博士生梦啊
那我这些这些同学们就得被迫过去当助教
是不是非常惨的一件事情
对不对
所以说啊救救孩子
这个我的工业界的伙伴们
真的我现在立刻马上真的就需要大家的支援啊
然后养一个博士生是非常非常非常便宜的
对工业界来说
真的每1年只需要5万刀左右啊
这么个意思
然后如果你有意向的话
然后请联系我
然后嗯不管是通过什么样的形式
比如说大家可以看
通常呢工业界和这个嗯
和和和学术界的合作方式
最简单就是给学生发奖学金
然后或者说发所谓gift founding
直接发到戏里面
然后呢或者是如果公司有一些跟rendering相关的
呃这些要求的话
然后又觉得我能力是可以的
那么我是非常开心
可以去给给大家当顾问的
那么国内呢这个合作与这边的合作是
几乎所有的公司都是可以的
只有一个公司
you know who
我就不再说了
这是确实是不行的
这不怪我好吗
这真的不怪我
这确实不行
其他的公司都可以
欢迎联系我好吗
然后然后真的是这样
然后我希望能够用这个诶
我的知识能够帮到大家一点
然后也希望大家能够帮到我一点
能够嗯让我能够比如说嘛招更多的学生
然后让学生们呢能够少做一些助教工作
能够更多地集中精力到呵这个科研中去好吗
然后至于我科研做的怎么样对吧
这个没必要再说了对吧
好的那么呃一个立刻可以做的事情是什么呢
就是说这个siggraph呢
我既然知道刚刚有一些paper中了
那么paper中了之后有一个重要的事情就是要写
致谢致谢里面呢大家可以看到啊
一个我之前写的致谢
就会把就会把啊日支持了这工作的啊
这些这些政府啊公司啊
写上名字啊
然后所以说如果你立刻联系我的话
是非常有希望可以感觉到你的
大家可以知道我的这个不管怎么样
论文吧
他是肯定可以嗯有着不错的曝光度的对吧
然后论文呢这个东西是永久的
然后只要写在这里
那是很多年他都会一直在这里的对吧
然后所以说在这里呢可以出现贵公司的名字
那我是非常开心的好吧
那我就说到这里
然后我另外说两件事
第一绝对不会通过任何个人的渠道
问大家收取任何费用
所以这课对同学们来说百分之百免费
绝对不会是任何问题的啊
另外一点我需要的银子是给到戏里面的
并且写清楚是用来支援学生的
我一分都不要啊
我说清楚我自己不缺啊好吧
然后呢唉另外有同学说说老师
啊然后我跟同学们说是完全没问题
致谢就是用来做这个的
我把你加上作者
那是绝对绝对绝对不可能的事情啊
就是说如果你给我银子
我是一定应该把你写到这个致谢里面去的
这是没有任何问题的对吧
并且我不止可以说这个对吧
以后有哎有人在问我说呀
是您最喜欢的这什么呢
呃最喜欢的游戏角色是谁
我就我就不再说是a2 了对吧
我就说我是我最喜欢月清书对吧
鹿鸣对吧
唉这都可以呃
嗯800比丘尼
哈哈哈哈对啊
然后还能想到什么
反正很多吧啊没关系啊
这么个意思啊啊行
对同学们来说没有任何的关系啊
是这个就是就是这么回事了
另外最后再说一句哈
那诶大家看到这个标题啊
food for thought啊
food for thought
其实是啊
这里算是直接字面上用它了
然后呢嗯呃呃呃如果你还知道啊
food for thought alt曾经是一个密码
那恭喜你
你跟我一样年龄大了
哈哈哈哈哈哈好吧行吧行吧
那同学们今天我就说嘛
我花点时间专门说一下这个事情
也是也是因为啊今天cirh非常开心
然后跟大家呃多讨论一些这些跟课程内容呃
不是特别相关的东西
但是呢有一点可以保证
绝对不会因此少了课程的内容哈
肯定是可以
哈哈哈哈哈哈呃行吧啊
那咱们这就算是进入到这正常的课程中来了
好吧
那咱们上节课讲了什么呢
咱们上节课讲了shadow mapping的一些问题对吧
也基本做法
基本问题基本解决方式
然后呢我们着重分析了一下
就是我随手写的一个什么样的一个一个公式啊
然后再在呃在呃整个实时渲染里面
大家是管这种方式叫做split sum
然后这块之后再给大家正式的引入
这么一个概念啊
之后再说嗯然后呢给大家说到了啊
作为percentage closer soft shadow啊
这块基本上来说tcs s从tcf开始对吧
然后到这块各个不同的地方
应该飞不同大的这种大小的区域啊
这块啊这么说清楚这个意思好
那差不多就是上节课说的这些内容
那么今天我们说什么呢
今天我们把这个啊pcf呃
和pcs s的这个内容在加强一下
我们在说的更加深入一点好吧
然后呢同时我们再引入呃
这节课要讲的一个新话题叫variance soft shadow map
作为vs s m啊
当然也有人管它叫vance shadow mapping
叫vs m问题不大啊
这个意思好嘞
那嗯行吧
嗯之后呢
在这在这个过程中
再跟大家说一下它的具体的一些实现方式
然后以及一个比它更高端一点的东西
叫moment shadow mapping
这样的话呢
我们差不多关于主流的阴影的技术就提到了
然后嗯这节课肯定讲不到
那么下节课给大家多少提一下基于距离场的呃
关于shadow mapping的技术
好吧
我们这个意思行
那这样的话啊
我们就开始第一个话题啊
咱们沿着之前上节课说的这个percentage
closer filtering对吧
大家看percentage closer filter做了什么事呢
大家还记得对吧
那就是说对于我实际渲染的任何一个点
大家可以从这幅图里面看到x
这部x呢我知道它投影到对应的shadow map上
应该是哪个像素
只不过呢我不只考虑这么一个角色
我考虑一下周围的一圈这些像素
甚至这些像素
它们的各自的贡献都可以加全的
它不一定是一个box
大家从这看可以有
比如说靠近这个p点的呃
他贡献多一点
远离他的少一点
没有关系
这属于取一个呃某种区域或者加权的区域
那在这个区域里面的其他的这些点
他们各自也都会在shadowmap上
记录着他们之前记录的最小深度
然后用这个深度同样跟x它的实际深度去比
然后我来判断这整个区域内到底有多少啊
这些嗯这text对吧
或者说fragment啊
挡住了这么个x这么一个点
对吧啊
然后这样一来呢
我就可以算出来
他们平均的这么一个visibility对吧
然后这样一来
我就可以把整个阴影给变得比较模糊
而这个过程正是我们在数学上直接说的
叫做filter或者convolution这么一个过程
好吧啊
那么这里呢就是差不多就是说这么个意思啊
然后大家看这个看这个公式
这个公式呢就算是一种简写
就是说如果我要对某一个函数
然后做一个convolution
我可以把它记住哦
用一个convolution w
然后打一个这个卷积
这个符号和f放在一块哦
把它定义成一个呃filter过来的
或者卷积过了的函数啊
这么个意思
然后呢呃那他实际上做了什么事呢
实际上就是相当于啊对任意一个呃像素p
我都取它的周围的一圈啊
这这呃淋浴啊
就是大家看这个nt就是他的淋浴
淋浴中间呢我去取一个啊嗯这个点点q啊
然后他的所有这些点q我都把它这么考虑下来
并且呢把这些所有的这些点q的值
然后按照根据啊
根据这个点q和点p
比如说他们之间的距离
然后做个加权
然后我把它最后的值给呃
重新写回这个点p的值
那说白了就是我们在电子101之前曾经提过
对吧
就是filter嘛
它其实就是加权平均
也就是convolution
我们并不怎么特别去区分它
那么在p c s s里面
我们到底做了一件什么事呢
那就是这样的
就是说我所谓filter的是什么
同学还记得吗
就是说对于任何一个神灵point x这里
然后呢我们都要去啊
考虑他在shadow map上这个某一个位置对吧
考虑到某一个位置
它周围的一圈啊这么个意思
然后他在shadow map上对应
那就是x那投影到shadow map上变成点p
那在点p的周围的一个区域
然后我们找它里面的这些所有这些点
考虑这些其他的点点q
任意一个点q是不是点q能够遮挡住x
那哪一个函数能够告诉我们
点q是不是能呃遮挡住呃这个x呢
哎那咱们就看这里就好了
那么这里是指什么意思啊
大家看这呃
不管怎么样
它是一个经典的一个filter的这么一个过程对吧
它是一个这是全这右边那自然就是直喽
那这个值自然就是阴影比较的结果咯对吧
我们之前说呃
我看这个点q能不能挡到x挡到的话
那这个visibility就是零嘛对吧
挡不到的话
visibility就是一嘛
所以这个函数它的值只有两个
对不对
只要么一要么是零
所以我们用这么一个函数
这个叫做k啊
这个函数念法
他在这个ltg里面打法就叫杠c h i啊
他念作k k这个函数
我们我们定义这个函数
叫做一个所谓的符号函数
符号函数是什么意思啊
就是说嗯嗯嗯这块在微积分里面其实也定义过
但是也非常简单
什么呢
它就是一个阶梯函数啊这么一个意思
然后他呢呃在呃
如果他的嗯变量就是整个它里面这个东西呃
就是就是它这个变量如果是呃大于零的
那我最后这个函数值k这个k函数的值呃
它就是一如果说它是小于零的
就是它里面的变量啊
嗯它的值小于零呢
最后结果就是零啊
这么个意思明白了啊
所以说那那这不就正是阴影比较的结果吗
对吧
我每一个点q它对应的深度和x的深度
我们比较了之后
然后我就呃我就可以知道哦
这个k这个函数告诉我们的到底是invisibility
是零还是一哦
那我把所有的这些点q它对应的visibility是零
还是一
按照某种形式加权平均起来
或者说我不加权对吧
然后那我得到的最后结果是不是
就是我这个x这么一个点
他的呃最后的这个p c s s之后的结果对吧
那就是这就是它背后的这么一个数学的公式
那么从这个数学的公式上
我们就可以看到说为什么我们说pcf这种方法
然后它并不是在filter shadow map
那filter shadow map是什么意思呢
那自然就是说
shadow map上记录了这么一个任何一个点
它对应的深度的值
那就是说在shadow map上记录的这个深度
在这q位置上对吗
那shadow map被模糊了
意思就是说我其实是相当于是呃profiltering
或者叫呃convolve呃
这样一个shadow map上面的一个图
就相当于我并不是这么做的
可以看到这里是一个不等号对吧
我其实做的是上面什么公式
我做的根本就不是说我先把shadow map做个模糊嘛
另外其实你如果做了shadow map的模糊之后
你再去做比较
不管你跟什么值比较
最后比较出来的值也是非零即一啊
对不对
那也就是说这样的话它并不能给你任意
那么另外一方面通过这种方式
你也可以直接就看到哦
我并不是说呃这个p c f呀
它并不是说在图像上去做一个啊
这么一个所谓的filter
咱们上一节课给大家提到的
对不对
就是说我最后啊
我已经得到了一个有锯齿的硬阴影了
然后我在这个一有锯齿的硬硬营商
我去做一个模糊
试图去解决抗锯齿的问题
那这种做法
那实际上就是在所谓
呃这么一个图像空间上来做哈
就是这么个意思啊
哎呀这里面有一个地方写错了哈
然后中间选一个y吧
咱们就不是p和q好吧
x的领域中选一个y
然后它的贡献就是x和y之间的某种距离
然后它的值就是之前在y这个点上
它对应的visibility啊
这么个意思好嘞
那行吧
嗯这就是在这个pcf嗯
它背后的这些知识啊
ok那这样一来的话呢
我们就说完了关于这块的pcf
然后呢咱们现在再回到说我们应用嗯
pcf去做啊
软硬影是怎么样去做的对吧
大家还记得这个事情好
然后呢嗯大家可以看一下
就是说我们上一节课已经说到了三分三步
对不对
分三步就是首先呢我要做一个所谓blocker search
这么一步
那么这block search是在干什么的对吧
他就是说啊他首先他的目的是为了决定说哦
如果我呃在呃shadow map周围
取悦某一个呃大小的区域啊
那么这个区域里面大概呃有多少是呃
这个呃所谓的blocker就是遮挡物
并且我算出来这么一个遮挡物的平均距离
我算这个遮挡物平均深度吧
这么说平均深度啊
average blocker depth
遮挡物的平均深度
虽然这个东西是干什么的
是为了第二步用的
第二步就是说我用这个遮挡物的平均深度
我就可以估算出我在第三部
应该在这个shading point周围
filter多大对吧
那咱们之前所说的就是这么一个逻辑了
只不过上一节课咱们是倒着说的对吧
然后呃那行啊
ok没问题哦
有同学说我之前slide有一个呃写错了是吧
p cf简称pcs s好吧
之后我看看你慢慢改
有同学问啊
为什么空间域的卷积就是加权平均呢
啊卷积实则就是差不多是呃家卷平均分
你可以试着把卷积写成什么呢
写成一两个函数乘起来
对应指相乘
然后再做积分这么一个形式
如果你把它写成离散化的形式
那就会变成了两个函数乘起来呃
然后并且外面把积分号改成求和号
而求和里面两个函数相乘
这不正是呃所谓加权平均的这么一种表达式嘛
对吧
这么个意思好吧
那咱们回到pcs s上来
他分这么三步
那么我现在问一个问题对吧
咱们上节课其实提了这三步中
哪些步骤是可能会比较慢的对吧
这是一个比较严肃的一个问题对吧
因为我们想着这p c s s呢
它可能会跑的比较慢
是因为什么呢
在这里写
原因
就是说我在第一步和第三步里面
都需要做这样一个操作
就是在整个一个区域内
我要看他所有的这些呃
呃这个区域里面的所有的所谓taxi
它上面记录的这个深度
并且跟某个深度相比是吧
第一步我肯定也要这么做
第三步我肯定也要这么做
如果我这这两步是这样的哈
这两步如果我不采样
那我取这么大一个区域哦
我知道他在texture上占据多少乘多少
这么一个格子
我不采用的办法
那就只能我每一个格子我都看一遍
是不是这个意思
那就是说呃这是一个非常缓慢的过程
那如果说好
我觉得这个区域太大了
然后呢唉我不想把里面的所有的text都看一遍
然后我想在中间随机取一些样本啊
这也是咱们的作业的一个实现方式啊
在这么一个区域内
我去随机的取一些样本
那这样的话
我就我我我也一样可以得到一个结果
只不过这个结果呢那自然就是近似的了
对不对
那就是这么一个一个思路
而这个近似会造成的结果就是所谓noise
就是最后的得得到结果
看起来就是噪声会很多
是这么个意思好吧
然后呢那同样它还有呃另外一个问题
就是说如果我之前不采样
那我最后我得出来哦
我应该filter一个巨大的区域
64x64
那我是不是说这整个64x64个txt
我都得走一遍对吧
那那这就会比较慢呀
那对于比较大的filter的范围
那么肯定就会比较慢
那如果说呃我去采样
那64x64原本那么大的范围
那我中间采样某个固定数量的三倍数
可以啊
当然可以
但是呢它造成的结果就是noise呗
之前我们说过对不对
那所以说呢这是一个比较啊严重的一个问题哈
那么嗯但是正常情况下大家所做的做法啊
我说一下工业界的正常的处理方案
就是这两部都是可以用我刚才所说的方式
去稀疏的进行一些采样的
就是说我确实可以去只看这一个区域里面的
某些txt啊
就是就是这么个意思
只看其中的若干个
然后呢
我自然就可以降低我访问这个text的这次数
对不对
那我两部都吸收采样的
我得到的结果那肯定都是有噪声的
对不对
那最后得到的结果
也就是说我就算做完了pcs的最后一部pcf
我最后得到的结果
那张图visibility
那么一张图仍然还是有这个噪声的
那么我们再怎么样处理呢
那这是一个自然而然的想法了
那我就做一遍所谓图像空间的一个降噪啊
这么个意思对吧
那这样的话这样的话是不是问题就可以解决
那么呃是是这样哈
就是说关于这块降噪
我原本安排的呢是这里来说
我们把它给拿到啊
real time retracing的时候再单独讲好吧
然后并且呢我会我会说这么一个事情
就是说呃关于降噪
它是时间和空间上
就是说关于图像域上可以直接去做滤波可以
然后还可以通过时间的累积来做这块
在之后都会说好吧
那也就是说关于怎么降噪
咱们就不再说了
嗯这次的作业也就是大家用足够数量的sample
虽然慢一点
但得到的结果是非常干净的
还是挺好的好吧
那咱们就先这么说着啊
ok那不管怎么样
咱们回到这么一个分析上来
哪些步骤可能会变得很慢呢对吧
那就是第一步跟第三步
所谓blocker search和这percentage closer filter filtering对吧
这会比较慢
于是呢我们嗯就想解决这两个呃很难的步骤啊
于是就有人提出了所谓various soft shadow mapping
一种新的思路好吧
大家从这个过程中就可以看到啊
大家还会再进一步体会到这么一个事情啊
就是说很多方法
就是说发现前面这些方法
在实际中有一个什么样什么问题
并且这问题在哪
然后我针对性的提出了一些解决方案
那这种v s s m自然就可以解决这个问题
好吧
那么讲之前
我看又有同学说边缘会不会flaker啊
那我先简单说一下
所谓flake呢
那就是说在不同的这些针
然后你每一帧可能会取的随机数不一样
那么也就是说你每一帧呢它的这些noise呢
它长得都不一样
然后如果你每一帧都是noisy的
然后你每一帧又连在一块很快的速度播放
你就会感觉他特别抖
这个就叫flaky啊
然后他会啊
我直接说他确实会出现这么一个问题啊
好的嗯
ok嗯这样有同学顺便问说多光源阴影会讲吧
不是特别会讲
可能会和那个和什么呢
和多光源的直接光照这块儿啊
放在一块讲吧
多少会提一下好吧
有一些游戏是会闪
就是说temporal就所谓在时间上
如果真的就是比较noisy的话
他就是会出现这个问题
以及我们之后还会说在dnoise的过程中
还会说就dnoisy啊
其实相当于是我们平常说的都是低通滤波
低通滤波就意味着低频的噪声也能通
那低频的噪声通了之后
然后你再哈哈你在做这个呃
比如说把很多帧都通过低通滤波呃
滤波过去了之后
然后直接在播放会产生一个叫做所谓boiling
artifact的东西
叫做呃沸腾的一个现象
然后所以有很多游戏
确实现在还会出现什么问题啊
ok那这是题外话
咱们就不再多说了
那咱们刚才所说的是什么呢
是嗯有人发现了pcs s啊
他在第一部跟第三部是有比较大的一些所谓
performance问题的对吧
那要是这样的话
那怎么样去处理呢
那就有人发明了这种东西叫v s s m
然后啊这是怎么做的哈
然后就首先它针对性的解决第一步跟第三步
在pcs中慢的问题
那咱们把它做的事说清楚好吧
然后呢那咱们怎么样去考虑它呢
怎么理解它呢
那咱们还是得从percentage closer来开始看
那么我们来看什么
我们看这么一件事情
就是嗯比如说啊咱们就说p cf也就是第三部吧
第三部我到底在干什么呢
第三部我是说啊
在shadow map上记录了这么一个区域内
我把他们每一个点或者每个text
它的深度我都拿到我来看
有百分之多少的这些txt
它的深度其实要比我的shading point要浅
我是不是想想问这么一个问题对吧
就是大家想一想
这是完全等价的嘛
哎我在这个区域内
我每一个点深度都拿到
然后跟我要比较的那个shading point的深度
我去比一下
得到一个结果
然后我再把这个这这要么1万嘛
我把所有比较的结果都给平均起来
假如说咱不加群啊
假如说不加群
那不就是意思在说哦
我想看这么一个区域里面
它有百分之多少的text
它对应的深度
其实是比我们的shading point要浅的嘛
对不对
这是完全相同的一件事
那他所说的是什么事情呢
咱们进一步理解
那意思就是说哦
在这个呃所谓嗯所要搜索的这么一个区域吧
就第三部pcf对吧
当我们确定了一个区域
这个区域里面呃
我就直接去找有多少呃
这些这些text
它的深度要比我们当前这个shading point的深度t
要小
就是这么个意思
那么这个问题听起来是不是
非常像另外一个问题
什么呢
就是说在一场考试中
你知道你自己拿了多少的分数对吧
然后你想问你现在是第几
是不是这个意思完全一样的道理吗
比如说对吧
你你你你就是咱们
比如说考试平均分是60分啊
然后呢呃你假如说呃考了比如说80分
然后呢你你这个你想知道你排第几
你排第几怎么办呢
那你就把所有的其他同学们的成绩都看一遍
是不是这意思
你看你你能排到百分之多少
这不就ok了嘛
对吧
倒不是第几哈
就是就是能排百分之几啊
这么个意思
那把所有其他同学的成绩都看一遍
那这正是我们之前percentage
closer filtering所做的一件事
对不对
那我们想避免的就是这么一个事情
我们不想把所有的这些成绩都看一遍
是不是
那么我们怎么样去解决呢
哎这就是vs s m啊
聪明的地方
那还是同样一个问题
而在一场考试中
有多少同学做的比你好
或者说你是百分之几这么个意思
那如果说我这场考试
我有一个呃每每个人的成绩
那自然就是刚才那种解决方案
那一个比它稍微不准一点点
但还不错的一个方法是什么呢
如果我知道这个成绩的直方图
这个直方图画的比较细
是不是比较好对吧
然后我就我就其实就可以知道哦
根据这个直方图呃
然后呢我落在哪
比如大家看看绿的这条嘛对吧
那我就可以知道我排第几了
是不是这么个道理
那么嗯更进一步往后面想
就是说如果你不需要那么准
甚至你连个直方图都不需要吃吧
那不需要你拿什么呢
哎你把它当成一个正态分布对吧
咱们之前统计上肯定是说过这么一件事情的
对吧
现在呢在这个呃呃就比如说在一个班上的诶
同学们的这些成绩
他大概都符合这么一种所谓的正态分布
这么一个形状
那如果说我就算知道这么一个正态分布
我别的都不知道
我不知道背后是直方图
我就知道这么一个曲线好吧
然后我同样还可以进四的
根据我实际的成绩
我在哪对吧
我知道
然后呢我就可以估计出我是前两轮几没问题吧
这肯定是可以的
那所以说这样一个这样一个思路就对了
就是所谓variance soft shadow mapping
意思就在这
就是说呢我要研究说唉
我大概在整个的这么一个范围内
我大概排百分之几
我其实是不需要知道
整个一个非常精准的一个分布的好吧
我只需要近似的认为哦
这个分布我可以认为是一个正态分布
那正态分布如果你想定义它
你需要什么呢
同学们可以想一想对吧
之前学呃正态分布的时候对吧
那我需要什么呢
我其实就需要两个事情
第一均值
第二房产对吧
就只要这两个事情
均值决定了它中心在哪对吧
他那个尖在哪
第二方差只是决定了它有多胖
有有有多瘦
然后由于它是一个概率分布
就是说它本身这个高度什么都是定的啊
它不是一个任意某种函数对吧
我只需要知道他的这个期望和方差
就就就就可以了对吧
呃均值就是期望哈一回事
然后那么这里v s m vs sm
那提出来的这个这个思路呢
呃就是如此
就是说呢我为了做第三部的pcf哦
我想知道我的这深度
在所有的深度中排百分之几
那我就把所有的深度的诶平均对吧
和它的方差在某个区域内
如果我可以快速的把这个信息给拿到诶
那我就立刻可以嗯做这个计算了
对不对
那么我们现在想啊
假如说给你一张shadow map
然后呢我给你框一块区域出来
诶
这块区域我问你这个区域内
它的平均值是多少对吧
哎那平均值是多少
这个听起来是不是非常非常熟悉对吧
诶我给你一张图
我给你签了某一个区域出来
然后呢
我想快速的知道它的整个这个范围内
的平均值是多少
那就没任何问题了
对所以有同学们就可以立刻想到哦
可以用meat map
对
咱们在这之前的这个呃101里面
我们就说了对吧
new map它发明来就是用来解决这一个问题的
所谓range average query对吧
然后他能解决这个问题
然后他当然有他的问题
咱们之后再说好吧
那么这里呢就是说啊我就先提一点map
map呢他毕竟是不准的对吧
它在不同层级中间还要插值
而且他只能做这方形的嘛
咱们之前说过map只能做方形的
然后他要是呃呃正方形的啊
如果说它是个长方形区域
你可怎么办呀
对吧
是这么个意思
那么一个更精准的能够求一个所谓
所谓任意的矩形的
一个在2d的一个一个表上面啊
给你一个任意的2d的一个矩形
一个更精准的这个数据结构叫做sunera table
简称s a t啊
ok那么这个东西呢马上我们也会跟大家说
那么这里提到两点意思呢
就是说不管我通过什么方式
我在shadow map上
我给你个区域
我我想知道他们记录的平均的深度是多少
我怎么算都行对吧
这两种方法都可以
马上我们详细说
但是咱们先这么着
咱们先考虑说哎那我反过来
我如果给你shadow map上一个区域
你你怎么立刻告诉我它里面方差是多少呢
是不是
这是不是一个比它比它的这一个区域内
平均要更复杂的一个话题
对不对
诶那这个要怎么做呢
那这个时候呢其实咱们这就是这vs s m啊
非常聪明的一点
它用到了一个超级经典的一个公式
什么公式
一个结合了期望与方差之间的关系
的这么一个公式
如果大家之前去学概率论
这个公式是必定必定是要经过推导的对吧
咱们之前是是要证明说哦
原来呃一个随机变量的方差
它应该等于等于什么呢
等于诶它的平方值呃的期望
或者说我把他所有取得值啊都取个平方
然后我再求平均啊
这就是平方的值的期望
然后去减去它的期望的平方
是不是
那同学们之前肯定都接触过
这么一个一个公式了
只不过这个公式怎么会突然就用到这里了呢
对吧
那咱们看一眼啊
我们刚才才说期望不就是算均值吗
没问题吧
那咱们shadow map里面存的是什么呢
存的是depth
就是distance
就是那些就是对应的x咯
那给你某一个区域
你肯定立刻可以得到他们的平均值
那么平均值的平方也就是后面一项搞定了
已经知道了
那么前面这块怎么办呢
这ex平方
也就是说偶我现在需要另外一张所谓的shadow map
这张shadow map里面
它的每一个元素记录的不是他的深度
而是深度的平方
ok诶是这么个意思
就是说它的他他这么一个shadow map里面
它是它是另外一个东西吧
它不是之前那个shadow map
它的每一个呃pixel它记录的值
它其实是其实是深度的平方
然后这样一来呢
我就同样还可以再做一个所谓范围的这个
平均查询
那我平均出来的结果呢
自然就是对于这个x平方得到的一个期望
对不对
哎那也就是说呃我为了算这个所谓的variance啊
或者叫方差呀
就是说我其实要做的是什么事呢
我只需要额外的一张shadow map
也就是说我之前一张shadow map呢
我记录了呃各个点看到的深度
我顺便我再把他的这个每一个点
看到的深度平方
我再把它升成另外一张shadow map
好吧
这是肯定是可以做得到的
那么在实际的这个操作过程中啊
在open gl里面大家都知道这texture嘛
一个texture它可能有四个通道
然后正常的你写depth的话
你只需要一个通道对吧
然后你写在比如说红色的通道里面
如果咱们不考虑特别高精度的话
一个通道够了deth
那我在绿色通道里面我就写上它的值的平方呗
然后这样一来我就根本就不需要用嗯什么呢
我我我根本不需要嗯额外的一个texture
对不对
我直接把它写在另外一个通道里面了
然后这样的话我也不需要什么所谓multiple render
target啊
这一系列的东西对吧
然后这样的话诶
直接我就可以在生成shadow map的时候
我想说的事就是这个顺手把这个所谓dex平方
它的这种shadow map也给生成
没问题吧
诶好那就没问题
嗯好那这样的话呃这就是刚才我说的意思了
就是说你在生成shadow map的同时
这个意思好吧
那也就是说其实你又没什么额外存储开销对吧
然后它生成的话
他你是顺手写的
你知道的depth你算个dex平方
这是个多快的事情啊
是不是
所以说呢咱们再来写进去
所以嗯呃就是这就能等于是虚
就就就就什么呢
就是说咱们回到刚才的呃
就是就是所谓high level到底我们在干什么对吧
我们其实就是说给你shadow map
周围的某一某一个区域啊
某一个区域
然后你去呃
能够快速的得到这个区域里面的平均和呃
就均值和方差
现在这两个事都能做到诶
是不是
所以说这是一个非常非常聪明的一件事啊
那沿着这个思路
我得到的均值和方差是要干什么来着
同学们还记得吧对吧
我是为了把整个这块分布
近似成为一个正态分布呀对吧
那么我自然就知道说哦
我有了均值
有了方差
我就有了正态分布
我有了正态分布之后
我现在再问哦
ok我知道它的深度的平均在哪
深度的方差是什么样的
然后实际gx的深度是多少
ok那我现在问有多少
这大概百分之多少的这些texo啊
它里面记录深度要比我记录深度小
有多少
要记录深度要比它要比它大呢
诶是吧
那这样的话其实我要求的是什么呢
我要求的如果大家还记得在概率论里面
大家说的
这就是所谓c d f对吧
cdf我们之前所说的这个分布呢就是pdf
那么咱们就跳过这么一个cdf概念了
咱们不说了
我们直接说什么呢
我们要的其实就是这个曲线下面的面积
ok对吧
大家看这么一个一个例子啊
假如说你有个正态的分布
正态分布的话
然后你假设你问我有百分之多少的值
是小于一的
这里哦哦我的鼠标应该在这哎好可以
大家可以看到有百分之多少的
这个值是小于一的呢
那我只需要统计这个面积就好了对吧
哎是这个意思好的
那么就是说如果说我对每一个这个值
我都去回答一下
有多少有百分之多少的值是小于它的
那么我再把这个函数给显示出来
那这个就是cdf啊
这里我们不不不用多说了
完全不需要多说
就是说呃呃差不多就是这个意思啊
然后就是说给你任何一个正态分布
给你某一个呃阴影呃
它实际的啊
shading point
他他在的这么一个位置
我立刻我就可以知道诶有多少的这个啊
呃百分之几的这个值要比他小
那么有同学就问了对吧
是说我到底该怎么去算这么一个曲线
下面的面积对吧
然后这一块儿的话呢
呃我我原本是打算多说一些了
之后再再看后面的应用是不是需要的吧
那这里我就简单跟大家说一下啊
对于一个呃所谓通用的高斯的pdf
就是说它会比那个所谓正态分布
其实要更那个要更精准一些啊
不是要更精准
更通用一些
它能够表示比它更多的东西
但都是这种形状
然后呢呃对于这一系列的这种pdf来说
然后他是直接可以可以把这个积分的值
给打成一张表的
而这个这个这积分出来的这么一个值
它其实是有名字
他这个名字叫做呃叫做error function啊
这名字听起来就是就是错误函数啊
就是那个error function这么个概念嗯
这块是这样
就是我原本呃就就这块
即使是我的离线渲染的这个课需要用到它
我也是把它放在呃一个一个
就所谓给大家参考的一个额外的一个嗯ppt上
那要不这样吧
我这块真的我不多说什么啊
对它叫误差函数对嗯
然后如果大家想知道的话
我把对应的ppt
到时候连着这个作为补充材料放出来
好了好吧
这里不再多说
然后想跟大家说的事情就是呃
第一这积分没有解析解
它能够能够写得出来
它能够有数值解
并且这个数值解c加加
还真有大家去找一个叫e2 f的一个函数
它就是所谓error function
然后大家可以在呃
就是任意的c加加的reference上面去找到好吧
叫e2 f这个函数就能做
这个就是就是所谓cdf
但是呢它能够竖直的帮你解出来
不代表这个呃就是所谓一个高斯的pdf
或者说一个正态分布
他的cdf是有解析解的
这是两码事啊
就是它它有数值解
没有解析解
那么自然数值解也比达比强嘛对吧
但是他就是说打表的话
你还得额外的存储
但是无论如何还是可以
那但是但是嘛咱们说诶既然是他这么麻烦对吧
那咱们算他肯定也挺麻烦
那所以说呢vs s m他又做了
另外一件聪明事
他干了什么呢
就是说他不知道从哪儿找到了一个不等式
哎大家还记得咱们上节课刚刚说过不等式
不等式这个东西在在哈
呃咱们这实时渲染中间是非常好用的
对不对
然后他找了一个不等式
这个不等式叫做什么呢
叫做切比雪夫不等式啊
这么个意思啊
这个切比雪夫他是非常有名的对吧
咱们这微积分里面接触了很多次
那么这里不再多说
多说这个人啊
那咱们说一下这个不等式是干什么
那这个不等式是这样的
就是说呢他可以告诉你一个
就是说一个随机变量
它取的值超过某一个值的概率
但是呢它又可以不履
不需要知道你这个随机变量
它所满足的具体的是一个什么样的一个分布
它只需要知道这个分布的期望和方差
ok是这个意思啊
就是说如果你有一个正态分布
确实你知道期望知道方差呃
或者说均值和方差
你是可以定义出一个呃
所谓呃就是就是正态分布的一个函数的对吧
然后你给你任何一个值
这个t你可以问哦
这整个呃大于t的这个概率到底是多少
也就是说在这个实际曲线下
它的呃就是打的这个这个红色阴影
这个面积对吧
但是切皮学富不等式告诉我们说啊
我们根本都不需要知道它是个正态分布
还是个别的什么东西
虽然它背后隐含着说
我会认为它是一个比较简单的一个分布
它是一个单峰的一个分布
挺像呃挺像这个呃呃正态分布的好吧
然后他能告诉你什么呢
他能告诉你说啊
我呃知道了一个函数
咱们看下面这张这张图哈
我知道这个这呃一个变量它的分布
它的均值一定在这
它的方差一定在这
至于它长得是不是这样一个虚线
这么一个所谓这个bell这个形状啊
呃我不管我不管
但是呢我可以回答这么一个问题
就是说如果我真的给了你某一数这个t
我我会立刻可以知道啊
从这个t开始
一直到这个曲线结束
到这个背后
它对应的面积不会超过什么呢
大家大家听我说
我说的是这这个面积不是说等于
而是说这面积不会超过这么一个东西啊
o所以说是这么个意思
就是对任意分布它算是的都可以这么这么来解
那么自然而然大家看这个公式好简单啊对吧
他就不用解什么error function对吧
然后嗯他直接就可以得到一个结果
而且你看他用到什么呢
你当然肯定得跟t相关的对吧
你t不同位置
那肯定是得到的值不一样
t变大的话
你就得出来的结果肯定越小对吧
这个意思就是有百分之多少的只是超过他了
然后他还用到这个分布的呃
所谓均值呃
缪和它的方差cm平方对吧
那也就是说啊这个公式它其实就可以告诉你哦
这块面积给你任何一个分布的平均值和方差
它可以告诉你这块面积从t开始到最右啊
它的一个面积的上界对吧
或者说或者说它的概率的一个上界
那但是呢
但是就是说还记得咱们上节课刚刚说的
这事儿对吧
就是说我们在呃实时渲染里面
我们平常不考虑不等
我们考虑的是约等
也就是说所有的这些啊不等式
基本如果要拿来用哈
都被人们给用来呃
当成一个约等式来看
所以这里呢咱们不考虑升上界
咱们就考虑这是一个对这个面积的一个
不错的一个估计好吧
那也就是说如果我有一个呃任何一个分布
我知道了
然后呃知道知道它均值方差哈
然后再给你一个范围
然后我就用这个公式吧
当等于
然后我就可以近似的得到后台
右边这块面积是多少
那这是不是就等于是这cdf我知道了对吧
那c d f是什么
不是从最左击到这块吗
就是左边这块面积
那自然就是一减去右边这个面积对吧
所以两边的这块我都知道好吧
那这块呢就是说这个切里雪夫不等式
他到底在说什么
他说的意思其实就是非常简单
给你均值给你方差
你不必知道它是一个呃
高斯的或者是正态的分布
那我还是可以近似的得到一个嗯它的cdf的值
虽然他是这是一减cdf这么个意思行吧
那也就是说大家就拿这个东西过来用
那就比刚才打表要方便很多了好吧那行
那这就是这么一个事情
但是但是啊千里雪夫不等式
它是有一个非常苛刻的条件
他说啊你要查询的这个呃任意一个变量值
这个t他必须得在均值的右边
他要在均值的左边
他们这么这么一个公式就不准了啊
这么一个意思
然后嗯这是一个非常神奇的一个一个事情吧
对吧
然后然后正常情况下
虽然他只有这半边是好用的
但是人们平常就一直这么用
然后效果还是可以的
所以大家可以看到在这么一个实时渲染里面
大家做了多少多少的假设对吧
一个是我我不用知道它分布对吧
这是一个另外一个这块的概率
它对应右边的面积其实只是一个上界
并不是一个真实的值
在最后他不是对所有t都好用的
它只是对这个你的任意一个呃x大于t
这个t他必须得在这个均值的这个右边
才能说这个好用
如果t在左边
那这个估计就不准了
还是这个意思好吧
那即便在这么多的限制条件下
人们还是用它
因为它太简单了对吧
看这个公式它不是比打表简单多了嘛
对吧好嘞嗯好有同学说卡了啊
我这样我先停一下啊
呃又有同学说没卡
可可我自己看我自己好像没什么问题啊
ok那我就先继续了好吧
那那行吧
就是这个意思就是说关于切比雪夫不等式
这怎么推的
那就是另外别的事情了对吧
然后就是说哎呀我一下看到了好多弹幕
好像是真的是会有一点点卡吧
ok啊嗯没关系吧
那我就先继续了好吧
那做了这么多工作之后
那咱们做一个简单总结哈
他要干什么
就vs s m
如果我想用它来提升我的第三步对吧
还记得吧
第三部p cf就单讲filter
这步我要我要怎么样用它来提升这个filter质量
那我怎么样做呢
那我就诶呃我就需要在生成呃
所谓depth map就是这个shadow map的同时
我还要把它的平方的值
然后也给写进去
写成另外一张理解成另外一张shadow map啊
然后我要做这么一件事诶那我还要干什么呢
哈哈哈哈对吧
然后这块就是我们刚才所说的
mip map或者s a t
然后待会儿要说这块
为了让你的嗯就是shadomap或者是平方的shadow map
他们能够支持所有范围的查询
你还要做什么额外工作
咱们待会儿说
那么呃这部自然都是你生成了shadow map之后
然后你要做的工作
那么我用shadow map的时候
那这就非常方便了
比如说我现在给你任何shading point
然后我给你刚才已经算好了的
各种各样的东西啊
deft deft平方直接map
然后我现在给你任何一个shadow map上的某个范围
然后我立刻就可以查到它的平均是不是诶
那也就是说这里oe解决问题
甚至它就是一次操作对吧
然后呢
那我这个诶这个平方的这么一个距离啊
或者深度诶
它这也是一张图嘛
然后我也取它的一个呃呃同样一个范围
然后取它的平均
然后这样的话有这两个信息
那我自然就知道了方差了对吧
所以均值方差就都知道了
然后那我要知道了均值
知道方差就等于知道了分布
知道了分布
我在嗯根据我这个shading point
他具体的真正的深度
我就可以立刻回答这么一个问题
在这么个范围内有百分之几的嗯
呃text或者说fragment挡住了他
那么挡住了多少
就意味着说他的visibility是多少啊
不就是说它的呃不可见的地方是多少对吧
比如说有30%的呃
呃东西我算出来
最后告诉我切皮学富告诉我对吧
有30%的text能挡住我这点
那我这点的可可见性
那可不就是0.7吗
就是visibility
直接就可以得到答案了
对不对
那这样一来哦
我根本不需要在这个范围内做任何的采样
或者是循环
是不是这个意思
所以说这是非常开心的一件事情
也就是说通过这种方式
我的第三步非常非常圆满的得到了一个解决啊
这么个意思
但是大家看到我这里打了一个问号
哈哈诶有同学问的非常到位啊
就是说如果场景中间有物体移动
你你就一定要更新mirap
真的是就是得这样
甚至来说啊
你你如果没有物体移动
光源移动也是一样的嘛
嗯对吧
然后就是说甚至在其他东西都是静止的情况下
只要你每一帧你是新生成的shadow map呢
你肯定要做这个呃
对应的这些mp map的这些这些操作
所以说它本身还是有一定的开销的
这是真的
但是话又说回来哈
是这个意思
就是说关于关于这一系列的这些操作
比如说给你一张图texture
然后你要生成它的mile map
这些东西呢都是gpu的硬件
支持的非常非常到位的一件事情
你几乎可以认为这些东西不花时间啊
可以这么理解
就是说生成这个实在是太快了
给你一张texture
然后你立刻生成它的map map
它会非常快
不过s a t会慢一点
咱们待会就会说好吧
那么嗯再说这个具体这块之前
那咱们先想办法把这vs s m啊
把这个事情和啊和什么呢
和和和咱们之前要解决的这两个问题
咱们这关系都得先说清楚对吧
我们现在说v s s m说到这里
其实要解决的是第三部pcf对吧
可是大家还记得一件事情对吗
就是说有两部都涉及到要采样
或者要在一个区域里面
我要找到他所有的值
那这也就是说我这第一步什么事情还没解决呢
对吧
那是不是不对
也就是说它只解决第三步的话
它并不能让这个方法变得非常快是吧
那怎么办
那咱们回到第一步上来看第一步在干什么
大家还记得名字叫blocker search
给你一个shadow map上的一个区域
我要问在这个区域内
它的平均的遮挡物的深度
ok那也
那也就是说
我要把他的所有的这些texo都走一遍
我要判断是不是这样的
如果是遮挡我
我把它的深度给累加到某一个什么东西上面去
对吧
然后我根据我最后累加了几个遮挡物
我把我这加核的深度除以呃
比如说呃总共遮挡物的个数啊
这样这不就是遮挡物的平均的深度嘛对吧
就这么一个思路对吧
那这是之前我们做的做法
那当然非常慢了
他就会非常的不高效
那它就会出现呃呃什么呢
就会出现说比如说这里诶5x5这么格子诶
我都得把它走一遍
是不是不太好对吧
那嗯这里面呢先区分一个概念
就是说我们要说的事情是遮挡物的平均深度
而不是在这整个一个块里的平均深度还是一样
我们看这个5x5的这么一个呃这个区域吧
那在这个区域里面嗯
假如说假如说我的一个嗯确定point
它对应的深度是七啊
假如说它对应的深度是七
那么只有说这些text就是一些蓝色这些txt啊
因为它们具能标注的这个呃
之前在shadow map上记录下来的这个距离
它要比这个七要小
它比七要小
所以说他们才是遮挡物
其他这些888999他们都不是遮挡物对吧
哎我们要算的是遮挡物的平均深度
是这么写
蓝色的区域
它的平均深度不是整个的平均深度
整个平均深度咱们刚才解决了
是不是给你一个区域
它里面记录的全是深度信息
我反正求个平均
那不就是整个的这个深度
也就是说the average
咱们假如说啊知道了没问题
那咱们不知道的是蓝色这部分的平均深度
是不是这个意思对吧
那所以说呢咱们要解决的
其实就是所谓的这个呃遮挡物的平均深度
下一步怎么怎么解决对吧
那这就是呃这块的关键的这么一个想法
嗯咱们做一个定义什么呢
就是说在呃我有一个shading point
它的深度是t那谁是遮挡物呢
那就所有所有它对应的深度小于这个t的
都是遮挡物
那就是蓝色
他们把它给记成它的平均深度啊
他们的平均深度虽然我不知道
我先把它记成z a clue呃
呃cluded啊
这么个意思
z o c c啊
然后呢
那同样道理
那不是遮挡物
谁不是遮挡物呢
如果这个z啊它实际深呃
这个shadow map上记录的深度它是要大于呃
我的仙灵矿泉深度
那它就不是遮挡物
那它不是遮挡物
它也可以有个平均深度吧
就是这些红色的这些颜色呃
这些text它的平均深度
我可以把它记成哎z ana cluded哎
这也没问题对吧
那所以说这样一来
咱们是不是有三个概念
整个的平均深度咱们知道早就知道了
整个这一块直接取一个就是mmap也好
s a t也好
取平均就得到了
那么我要求的z a clude
然后我不我我这the cluded
可惜不知道
然后呢
我这zana glude
an an accluded吧
就这样说
这块区域的平均是多少呢
呃我也不知道
但我也不关心
不是这个意思吗
对吧
然后所以说我最后要的就是遮挡物的平均深度
那么这就是这vs s m在这第一步所谓block search中
他做了一个聪明的一个做法
那那还是一样
照我们刚才整理的这么一个思路啊
我们要计算的就是遮挡物
也是蓝色的这块平均深度
然后呢哎我们这这也有另外一方面的呃
这块不是遮挡
我们平均是我们不管
但是他们总归得满足这么一个关系吧
这是什么关系呢
诶大家看啊
也就是说啊
比如说我有n一个呃
非遮挡物总共是n个
然后非遮挡物的平均值是这么写
然后我n2 个这个遮挡物
然后总共也是n个
然后这是遮挡物的平均深度
哎我这是在干什么
我这不正是在做这个事情呢
就是说哦这里是一个比例
对不对
n一除以n就表示说诶
非遮挡物占据的比例是多少
然后他们的平均深度是多少
然后遮挡物它整个在这个里面占据的比例
大概百分之几都是遮挡物对吧
然后它的平均深度是多少
那我自然而然诶
我把他们这按照这个百分比给平均加圆起来
他们肯定就得等于总共的呃
嗯这整个一二块他们所有的这个深度的平均了
那肯定是这样的
只有这两种呗
只有这两种平均的这个深度嘛对吧
每一种平均深度是这些
然后每一种各自占的比例是多少
他们把加起来肯定就是总共的平均了
这是一个非常直观的一个呃观察
但是它非常有用
什么呢
就是说啊大家看这个事情
就是说n一除以n对吧
n一除以n是什么
就是说嗯没有被遮挡住呃
就是说不会是能够遮挡住我
shading point的这么写txt
它到底有占了多大比例
那这是什么意思呢
对应到切比雪夫上
大家想刚才那个分布啊对吧
这这所以有同学问的非常好
对
这不能用之前正态分布
假设正是用它的时候
正是用它的时候
这个嗯这个假设我不管是用正正态分布也好
我用切碧雪肤也好
唉他都可以告诉我有百分之多少的呃
这这些呃呃txt对吧
有百分之多少的tt
它的值要比我的当前这个深度要大
那这不正是切比雪夫直接告诉我们事情对不对
哎那所以说我就立刻可以得到这么一个百分比
那我知道这个百分比值了
我我另外一个百分比
那不肯定是一减它嘛
对不对
他俩加起来是百分之百嘛对吧
就是说比如说我有百分之呃
30的都不是遮挡物
那另外70%肯定就是啊这个意思
那这样一来的话
哎我这两块的比例我知道啊
那咱们看一看啊
我们要求的什么来着
我们要求的是这个呃
they are cluded
对吧嗯
那那我们知道它整个一大块中间平均是什么
我想知道它的诶遮挡物的平均深度诶
可是我偏偏我不知道这个东西怎么办对吧
我不知道说非遮挡物的平均深度我不知道
不知道怎么办呢
那这个时候就是他的一个更大胆的一个假设
不知道是吧
好没关系
我就认为你的非遮挡物的深度
都跟我当前的shading point的深度一模一样
也就是说比如说我的那个shading point
那块的深度是七啊
那这些888999全部都是七啊
这么个意思好吧
哈哈哈哈哈哈啊行吧
所以说啊这是一个不得已的一个假设哈
但是我觉得这么假设的问题不大
为什么呢
因为绝大多数的阴影的接收的东西是个平面
想一想这个事情对不对
绝大多数阴影的接收者是个平面
如果真的是个平面的话
你就这么假设问题不大对吧
那所以说这其实它背后有一点点它的道理
那么这样一来的话呢
哎大家看average的话
唉我一次呃这个所谓范围查询就查出来了哦
这n一除以n切比雪夫
n2 除以n一减切比切比雪夫对吧
然后z n a cluded
就是当前那么一个值是神经控制
剩下什么z o cc啊
解决了哈哈哈哈对吧
就是通过这种方式哎直接就可以解决了
让大家看他做了件什么事对吧
他同样就是为了解决他的第一步
所谓呃呃呃这叫什么来着
block search对block search
然后这一步他用到的一个核心的
就是这么一个观察
就是这样一个公式了对吧
这个公式是肯定百分之百对的
然后呢他就是说这些比例的什么东西
他就用这个借比雪夫来告诉我们
然后他这总共平均呢直接通过范围查询呃
然后再做一个假设
哎
我最后可以把遮挡物的平均深度就拿下了对吧
所以说唉这是一个非常非常聪明的一个做法
那这里就是呃v s s m能够做到的一个效果
那大家可以明显从这个图上来看
这是两个光源对吧
大家看到两个阴影交叠在一块
然后呢看起来真的是不错对吧
然后嗯当然了
他有他的问题
咱们待会儿就会说啊
嗯不过呢到这里这样哈
我先放到这一页呃
现在同学们可以问一下问题
然后呢我我先说一下
就是说vs n s m
他确实那这这这些做法他实在是太聪明了
就是说我每次我觉得我是嗯再思考一遍
他到底是怎么做的
我觉得有很多很多很多超级大胆的假设
然后但是同时他也有很多非常这些
很精髓的一些观察
对不对
就像刚才那么一个按按照比例去加强
他们的平均深度这么一块
然后我就觉得
虽然啊咱们先说清楚
虽然在实际的操作当中
就是人们现在
现在更多的会去用pcss来做阴影了
为什么呢
这里说一下
就是说人们现在对噪声的容忍度
现在是越来越高
而为什么是这样
正是因为现在对呃图像空间做降噪的这个手段
现在是做得越来越好
特别是有了这个空间和时间
这么两个东西结合在一块儿做降噪
效果就会特别的好
而这个整个这些东西都应该归功于
一系列的这些所谓temple的方法
比如ta咱们之后还会再说好吧
然后就是说现在人们说
你能够比较快的得出一些有噪声的结果
我觉得问题不大
之后
一定是有办法可以把这个噪声干掉
好吧
咱们这么说清楚
这就是为什么现在渐渐的pcs s要压过vs呃
呃v s s m里头啊
这么个意思好
那诶我来看看啊
同学们说嗯接收平面要是曲面怎么办
诶这是说的非常好
不只是曲面
甚至跟光源不平行的时候
就已经会出问题了对吧
然后就是说确实是会出问题啊
然后这些就是所谓的这些
我就说嘛咱们在做呃实时渲染的过程中
有很多这些理论说的挺挺挺明白
但是在实际操作过程中就会出现一些问题
确实是会出问题
大家可以自己试一试
artifact啊
挺明显的
做作业难吗
作业不难啊
作业嗯就是简单的p c s s没让大家写vs m吧
啊这个意思啊
好吧哦
v s s m是p c s s的快速版本的
可以这么理解吧好吧
可以这么理解
然后就是说他嗯但是你不能替换tcs s
我觉得p c s s可以作为一个所谓的baseline啊
可以作为一个可参考的一个标准
然后目前来说反正大家就用它效果挺好的
我们这里有
我刚才不是说了嘛对吧
我们我为什么要讲这vs vs s m
因为他实在太聪明了
这个中间这块
而且呢确实它可以做得非常非常的快啊
而且他是没有任何噪声的对吧
那这多好呢对吧
然后如果他要写的话
其实我挺建议
那这个同学们自己没事写一写这个v s s m
然后它中间涉及到很多技巧的
特别之后我们要说的这些算法啊
这个事情啊
好哦
我再强调一下
vs s m并没有用正态分布去估计
他用的是切比雪夫
然后就是说我说正态分布
只是为了方便大家理解一下
就切比雪夫根本连正态分布这么一部都都不用
不用经过他就已经可以得到他的c d f呃
有意思啊
ok嗯好吧嗯噪声我其实之前说了
我就不再多说了
好吧
这这这那那现在我把这剩下来的这些这些嗯
内容呃
我快速过一遍吧
好吧啊行
那咱们下一步说什么
咱们下一步说一个遗留问题
在v s s m中间啊
嗯嗯就是说他的一个具体的实现什么
具体的实现是一个为了让所谓shadow map
或者说嗯嗯就是记录了深度平方的那么一种
shadow map
能够支持范围查询
我们还要做一个事情对吧
我们毕竟要生成这个呃milk map或者是sa table
然后嗯这块之前nvidia的一个经典做法
就是它引入了一个呃这个sound era table
这么一个概念
所以说咱们把这整个这块给说清楚
这样算说完好吧
然后呃还是一样啊
为什么要说他是因为咱们之前说了
给你一个范围
你要快速的得到它的均值和方差
然后为了快速得到均值和方差
我其实要快速得到这个范围内的深度平均和
深度平方的平均对吗
那么呃这两个其实咱们就把它当成一回事吧
那咱们就现在假设呃把它给抽象出来
变成一个更通用的情况
现在就给你一张图
给你一张图
我现在要问呃
给你这张图上的任何一块区域
然后这块区域我应当如何去快速的得到它的呃
一个平均值
这么个意思啊
并且呢这块区域我保证它一定是一个矩形
好吧
这么个意思嗯好那么呃最简单的做法
那肯定就是mip map
咱们之前说过对吗
map map如果大家还记得咱们在game z101 里面
map map做的是什么
做的是快速的近似的方形的范围查询
没错吧
然后就是说即便是方形
它也不见得就是说可以做到呃百分之百精确
为什么呢
因为它有差值
一个典型的例子是这样的
就是说比如说咱们这一块
大家看到这个level 5对吧
这milk map不就是一张图
我可以生成它的这每一次减小一大分辨率
然后生成另外一张图啊对吧
这个意思
然后现在如果我想求原图上对应这么一个哦
我的天我的鼠标不在这
ok原图上对应这么一个区域哈
啊呃这块它的值是多少呢
哎那我直接到level 5上去取这个像素
它对应的值是非常精确的一个值对吧
那如果说我是原图上
这个我稍微把那个正方形啊往右下偏那么点
但是又没偏到这个位置
我偏到天道这中间某一个位置怎么办呢
那我是不是要对这四个地方进行一个差值对吗
插值出我的鼠标现在悬停的这么一个位置
它的值到底是多少
而这个差值就不怎么准嘛对吧
只要涉及到差值
差值肯定是猜出来的吧
而且这还不是关键
关键是如果说我有一个查询的范围
它不是比如说二的多少次方
那么大小边长的一个正方形
它是个正方形
但是它的边长比如说它是六
那你可怎么办呢
那你是不是要到
比如说第二点多少层去找他对吧
二点多少层找他怎么做呢
还记得吧
三线性差值就是层与层之间
我还要再做一次差值
那这样不是更不准吗
意思就是说啊mip map能不能做范围差距
能但是不准啊
这么个意思
而且咱们刚才所说的都是说关于这个方形
正方形这的这样一个查询都已经不准了啊
更不用说哦
我如果还有个长方形
那不就是不好做了吗
各项异性过滤能解决这个问题啊
ok那但是咱们在这里要说一个
百分之百准确的一个方式来实现它
那这怎么做呢
这就是大家引入的这么一个数据结构啊
叫做some area table
然后同样这个sama table呢
它是紧密的和一个什么东西概念呢
和一个算法的概念叫做前缀
和这么一个概念结合起来的
那么他是做了件什么事啊
其实他做的事情挺简单的啊
别忘了他的最早他要解决什么问题来着
他要解决范围查询对吗
范围查询意思就给你一片区域
你立刻能得到它平均
那么我现在来说这么一个事情啊
就是说他其实啊范围内求平均
跟你范围内求总和是不是完全有概念吗
没问题吧
你得到平均之后
你反正你知道范围多大
你去乘以这个范围内的这些元素个数
它不就是总和了吗
对吧
你知道总和之后
除以这个元素个数不就是平均的吗
所以这是一回事啊
就是范围内求和跟范围内求平均一模一样概念
那么咱们现在假设看这么一个事情
就看这个input啊
大家看一个数组一维情况下
一个数组那一维情况下范围查询是什么意思
给你一个连续的某一段对吧
告诉你这一段它里面的值到底是平均是多少
或者总和是多少
那么总和是多少呢
那比如说咱们以刚才呃这个为例啊
以以这样一个一维的数组为例
那么我需要把三把七把一给加起来
总共11
是不是这个意思
这没问题吧
对那我就说呃我为了算它它的复杂度是多少呢
他肯定是o n的呀
因为说你这个范围如果给的非常大
咱们给一个巨大无比的从头到尾的
那你是不是要所有东西都给加一遍
那你现在就是不想要把它给加一遍了
对不对
那这个时候人们就提出了一种数据结构
叫做some area table
那么对于一维的这个退化情况
我不知道应该管它叫什么
咱们还管它叫s a t好吧
s a t干什么呢
对一维的情况它非常简单
他做了一件什么事
做了件预处理的事
玉书里你拿到这么一个呃这个啊这叫什么呢
呃数组啊
一维的数组
我先花o n的时间
我从左到右走一遍
我走一遍的时候
我就把它对应的这每一步的累加的和我给加上
比如说我一开始在一
那么它从最左加到这个的值
它就是一
然后我往右走一格走到三
那我原本已经得到了一了
我把三给加上
得到了四
然后我再往右走一格
然后呢我就我就会算哦
我刚才已经得到了40这个核了
那我要是走到这个点的话
从左到右总共加起来是多少
那就4+5
那就是九
然后每次我就把这些每次拿到数看见没
每次拿到一个数
就把它加到这个前面一个值上去
那我最后得到结果
那可不就是这41就是总共的总和对吧
然后那这样说
咱们的一个精准的定义就是sat上任何一个元素
它表示的都是原本的你这个一维的数组
从最左边的这个元素加到这个元素
它的和是多少啊
这没问题对吧
那这样一来的话
他有什么好的办法能够方便我来做这个查询呢
那就是说啊大家看这个查询
他可以做到这么一个事情
就是说我不是要求这么一段呃
这三这七是一吗
然后然后他加起来等于多少
这里有一个经典的一个思维方式
这一段加起来等于多少
那就好像是说我这这个整个的前六个数
形成了这么一段
它的和减去我这前三个数的这一段
它的和看见没
我中间的任意一段
我都可以把它给描述成前面多少遍
这是前六项呃
德和减去前三项的和
那可不就是剩下456的嘛
对吧
哎那这里面那我问前六项加起来的和是多少呢
我刚才已经算了s a t比20
然后前三项加起来和是多少九
那我只需要我为了回答这三个呃
值加起来是多少
我只需要找到哦
它对应的这个终点
找到它起点前面一个啊
然后前面起点前面一个
那他们一减哎
20-9多少十
一正21 3+7+1嘛对吧
就是这么一个一个嗯很简单的一个思想
那他做的一个事情是什么呢
就是预计算的
就是他虽然这个o n呢他还是要花的这个世界
但但是呢他是你
反正这个数组它本身他他就是那么些数
然后你要知道这些数也是欧文对吧
你要你后他就开了一个额外的欧文那个空间
然后呢他又花了欧文的时间把数组走
那边就做了这么一个事
哈哈就这么一个事情
这个算法也太过简单哈
就是不叫太过吧啊确实可以这么说吧
就是说这个算法是嗯
就属于说就算在面试中
也算是相对低端一点的题目
就是说这块来说啊
嗯确实挺容易啊
前缀和思路
那么到二维的情况下
唉二维的情况下是什么样子呢
唉那这是我们要解决的问题是吧
二维的情况下就看这张图就好了好吧
这是什么意思呢
二维的情况下
你有一个任意矩形
而任意矩形啊
但这算是所谓axis aligned的矩形
我们不让它能旋转啊
不不不行
那不行
就是它必须横平竖直的矩形
那这个矩形里面的所有核啊
大家看看这个矩形里面所有的和
咱们是不是可以理解成
诶这个绿色的这么一个矩形
从左上角开始的啊
看一下啊
从左上角开始的这么一个绿色的矩形诶
我先减去左半边
减去左半边这个黄颜色
这个矩形看见没
然后呢我再减去上面这这这半边黄颜色矩形
然后你会发现不对劲对吧
我我这是不是多剪了一个
这最上面这么一个小的矩形对吧
我再把它加回来
这是最简单的容斥原理啊对吧
然后就是说嗯大家可以体会一下对吧
这个绿色减掉左边一半嗯
就剩右边一把又减去上面一半
你就上面左上角有多减了
把它加回来
那可能就最后变成你你就要的蓝色这块了吗
那么这四个矩形
这四个矩形在这四步操作中
它都有一个明显的特点
什么呢
这些矩形的起点都是左上角
看见没有
都是左上角
那同样道理
我们用刚才的所谓some area table sat的这样一个道理
我可以预计算一张表
这张表里面任何一个元素
它所表示的都是从左上角加到这个元素
这整个一个矩形里面的值对吧
那这样的话我我这所有这四个这四个矩形
我都可以通过查s a t对应的这么一个元素啊
对应这么一个元素
白色的看见没
我就可以在sat中求这么一个值啊
然然后我只需要查四次这个表
大家可以看很明显
查四次
我得出来的s a t
我立刻就可以得到这么里面的一个精准的一个
呃求和对吧
是这个意思
好啊
哦我倒是有同学说这个图应该以右下角为坐标
可能好一点哦
有道理
但是这样哈
反正就是说呃他就把这个箭头给忽略了好吧
就算是这些所有东西都是从
都是从左上左上角开始
那么同样道理哈
那在二维的情况下
你如何去建立这么一张s a t呢
那那这个其实是很好做的
什么呢
每一行不都是一个一维的意味的一个数组嘛
你都这么做是吧
每一行都这么做
然后做完了之后
你是不是每一行的一个呃
每一个点都表示哦这一行从左加到右
加到我这个当前这一点它对应的值
然后呢我每一行都这么做
做一遍之后
我再把每每一个列就竖直着
我再做一遍
就是这样的话
我是不是就就可以得到任何一个这点
就现在s a t中间这么一个白色的一个点
它描述的就是哎这么从左上角开始
一直加到它的值是多少对吧
那所以说只用横着做一遍
竖着做一遍
那么横着做一遍
每一个呃行我都是o n的
那么整个算起来那就是m乘n了对吧
然后呃就是行和列的这个呃呃个数各是多少啊
嗯就是就是这么说
就多少行多少列嘛
假设说m行n列
那就是mn这么个时间
那么水平一遍竖直竖直一遍
它还是mn这么个时间
但是同学们肯定会想起上一节课我就说了对吧
就是说嗯
那咱们图形学中
关于这个复杂度的这么一个事情啊
是一个非常不认同的一件事情
对不对
哈哈哈哈啊
ok哦是这样哈
就是说我这里写o n
这个n指的是指的是所有的这些元素的个数啊
如果这样理解的话
那它就是就是o n的哈
然后呢如果准确来说
那就是o m乘n了啊
没问题啊
都是对的
好的
那么这里呢那哦有同学问他s a t会不会溢出
就是说分辨率很高的时候
那这位同学问的
肯定就是说是他的数值精度的问题
是会不会溢出对吧
他肯定不是说存储
因为存储来说
它的s a t的存储
跟你原图的存储是一模一样的
这是没有问题的对吧
然后所以原图存得下你s a t
你就可以认为存得下就是o n的时间
o n的存储没问题
然后呢嗯就是说呃呃关于数值精度累加
它总归是会损失数值精度的
这是肯定的
所以说它确实是会有这样一个问题啊
嗯但是问题不是特别大
那么这里面我想说的一个问题是什么呢
就是s a t
大家看起来这个复杂度是o n的对吧
然后我刚才提到这么一个做法啊
如果你横着做一遍呃
竖着做一遍
那你横着做一遍的时候
就说每一行可以单独呃进行
就是我在算第一行的时候
跟第二行一点关系没有对吧
也就是说行与行之间是可以并行的对吧
然后这种情况下
就是就是说呃它的并行度还是有的
没什么
没什么特别大的问题啊
也就是说你可以通过gpu
然后可以让它变得比较快
但是这个我之前说过这么一件事对吧
gpu的并行度是远远比这个行数要高很多的
然后这样一来的话就会嗯
就是就是说如果你这个算法写得不好的话
呃就这个病情很可能还是会有点慢啊
这么个意思啊
这就是为什么我如果我没记错的话
我记我记得我记得呃
我记得nvidia放出来过一个什么样的实践
来来做这么一个s a t就直接把它给写出来
然后我自己年轻时候我还写过一个
然后嗯就是这么个意思吧
就假如说你已经有shadow map了
就是open gl生成的open gl生成的呢shadow map
它肯定是个texture
它肯定在gpu里
然后呢
我把它给当成一个呃coda的某一块的这块内存
我可以去访问它
然后用库大去呃
呃这还是可以的
但是如果我没记错
当时写的还是很不是很快的啊
这么个意思啊
然后呢呃这么个意思吧
也就是说呃这里虽然都是o n
还是回到咱们之前实时渲染考虑的问题
我不管是不是o n
我只管它实际上跑的是不是足够快
这么个意思好吧
嗯行吧
那差不多就是这么个意思吧
就是s a t嗯这块的构建以及它的使用
那咱们就都说清楚了
这样的话vs s m这块应该没什么死角了
应该都已经呃覆盖到了
我来看看同学们还有什么其他问题
不就是说我们其实现在还差最后那么一点点啊
最后那么一点我也就那就这样哈
反正今天啊这这这这因为sirup这个事情了
多耽误时间
然后所以说今天是真没办法了
我待会花几分钟把它给说完好吧
嗯有同学问我为什么要用q弹
当然用shader也可以写了
问题不大
就是说嗯sat就确实是不怎么特别好用的啊
不是不怎么特别好用
就是说它本身呢它还是有一定的开销
可以这样说啊
就是说嗯mip map的话
这里我再多说一句
就是说大家看mip map
它我刚才不是说是近似的嘛对吧
然后他在这个阴影比较小的情况下
也不是阴影
就是软硬的
你要过滤的范围比较小的情况下呃
还是可以的
但一旦大了之后
大家会看到明显的一些artifact啊
这个意思好嘞
哈哈哈哈哈好
ok那行s a t不是前缀和啊
sa t是一个数据结构
它对应的这个算法叫前缀和算法啊
这个意思啊啊不过没关系了
区分这个干嘛呀
嗯反正一个意思哦
用computer sciator也可以呀
对呀肯定是可以的
对嗯
就是就是说怎么样去算这个s a t
这个问题不大
但是呢
确实刚才就之前有个同学提到这个事情了
就是说我每次生成shadow map
我肯定就要重新算一遍mile map
或者是或者是它的对应的at对吧
然后这肯定是要花时间的
这是真的啊
ok所以说这部分得要足够的快
k s t横向二维的c e f是挺像的
哈哈哈哈是挺像的啊
ok好那那行吧
那这样的话
那我就顺便把这最后这么一点给给说完啊
嗯就是说最后我们要提到
一个非常前沿的一个东西
叫做moment shmap
不是不算特别前沿的
但是就是说中间呃应该是1度有人用
然后后来就还是一样嘛
就是因为所谓temple filter的方法
现在变得越来越流行
所以让之前的pcs s
所谓这个啊重新焕发升级啊
这么个意思
所以moment gle mapping渐渐的没有人
没有特别多人用啊
他确实实现起来有点麻烦
这是真的
那么他到底在干什么对吧
咱们还是按之前的经典思路来
就是说
那么我们既然提到诶
v s s m发明了
是为了解决这么一些哈哈
这个呃tcs s的问题对吧
那他自己会不会有问题呢
呵呵有对吧
他的问题是什么呢
那咱们刚才说了哎正好有同学问对吧
就是说v s s m的问题是什么呢
那咱们从这幅图就可以看出来了
正是因为他是做了很多假设嘛
对不对
那他的假设不对的时候
那不就出了问题了吗
那他假设什么时候不对呢
那我这里咱们先看左边这幅图
看左边这幅图呢
它这里有一个shading point
shing point呢
它比如说光源在这边对吧
光源应该在这投影嘛
然后我会看到哦
他这里有这么这么些可以遮挡住他的东西嘛
对吧
因为你想这个点可能对应的就是shadow
shadow map上的某一个pixel
然后shadow map这个pixel周围的那些pixel
记录的可不就是这些数值这些东西
他们的这些深度这些分布吗
这些是树枝什么东西这么这么复杂
呃
我把它当成一个正态分布
好像并没有什么问题对吧
那所以说我就可以得到这么一个结果啊
ok那这里呢问题就不大
那么什么时候会有问题呢
那自然就是说我不能认为在这个范围内
他的这些呃集合就是它的fragment或者text
它的分布还是一个正态分布对吧
或者说一个光滑的一个呃
一个所谓single logo的一个分布
不能这么假设
什么时候不能这么假设呢
其实有一些简单情况反而你不能这么假设
比如这个时候
假如说你这个shading point还是shading point
我往某个方向看
我会发现他正好穿过就这三个片好吧
就正好穿过这三个片儿某一个位置
然后呢
那这里实际上来说它对应的这个呃分布啊
就是遮挡物
它们的分布就是也不是说这一根光线穿过啊
就整个这一片吧
这一片它的分布很明显
它应该是会集中在这三个这个呃
深度的附近对吧
也就是说它不一定是这么三个delta
他应该是很明显的三个呃不同的峰值
就是说如果说你往这个方向去找到它对应的
shadow map的pixel
取它周围的一片
你肯定会看到那么一个分布
而那个分布三个峰值的
你怎么可能拿一个呃高斯来描述它呢
哎这时候就说明你描述的不准对吧
哎描述的不准会出什么问题吗
那这是我们要关心的事情对吧
那描述的不准会出问题
会出问题出在哪儿呢
那是描述的不准
那可不就是说你最后算那个百分比算的不准吗
咱们就假设先不考虑是什么blocker search内部吧
那咱们就只考虑最后的p cf这一步
那我p cf最后就是为了告诉我一个百分比呃
多少挡住他
然后我那我那我这一减多少呢
自然就是我最后的visibility了
对不对
那那像这种情况
如果你不准
那你得到的结果要么大
要么小呗
就是这个意思
那如果说你得到的呃
说你原本啊应该实际上有个30%的
这些呃taxi能够挡住你当前的shading point
但是呢呃您用那么一个不准的分布
然后你估计出了50%
那这就说明他会偏黑了对吧
你得到结果就会偏黑了
偏黑了怎么办呀
那就偏黑了呗
通常情况下人们是能忍的
就是结果就是有一些地方他不该那么黑
就是他反正阴影了对吧
他黑了就黑了
那么但是有一个问题
人们非常不希望在这个阴影的某一些地方
突然变白了
这是一个非常严重的问题
ok那么这个问题怎么样去理解呢
咱们就看下面这幅图
这幅图就比较清楚
大家可以看到
比如说实际的一个遮挡物的分布
它其实这么一个非常不规则的一个东西来看啊
大概是这么回事对吧
然后呢诶我不管三七二十一
我用的还是这么一个正态分布去描述它
那我我我们之前刚刚说这个不管是什么
真的用正态分布还是切力雪佛
他都会假设大概有一个那么样的一个分布
然后那这时候我会估计出什么来诶
我会估计出哦有百分之这么个红色面积
它算是能挡能挡住我这个shading point
然后实则是呢
这个呃
呃不是不是不是他的深度会比这个shading point
他要大
就意味挡不住啊
挡不住
然后它实际上来说只有那么小的一部分
蓝色的阴影面积是深度要大的
也就是挡不住的
那也就是说你这会造成的一个结果
就是假如说他实际只有20%都挡不住
然后你先告诉他
这有有50%的都挡不住
那就得到结果呢不就会变白吗
就是说这两种情况肯定都会发生的对吧
诶变白了会出现一个什么情况
就好像会出现这么一个情况一样
大家看这个车子哈
大家看这车子
看这车子有没有感觉哪个地方特别奇怪
哪儿呢
这儿大家看见没来看这块
就正常情况下
这个车子底下得有底板的
没问题吧
对他肯定不可能光直接照到它
那为什么这里面它突然会变白了一下呢
哎那这里大家就可以可以解释了
就是说啊
这车大家看起来是一个非常镂空的一个情况
对不对
也就是说如果我这个shading point
往light那个方向上去看
我会看到哦
有一部分这些呃text哦
就是就是说对它的深度就集中在这个附近
还有一些零零散散的深度集中在这个附近
就是它不是一个镂空的吗
还是车子上面有个夹子嘛
对不对
然后就是说底板上这是一块
然后这个这个天窗上这这边又是一块
然后它很明显它不是一个正态分布吧对吧
它不是个正态分布
你强行拿正态分布去描述
它肯定会变得有的地方暗
有的地方亮对吧
有的地方暗的地方你看不出来
有的地方亮你就会看出问题了
就好像是这light会渗过去对吧
就是说这个就是管它叫做light leaking
没问题吧
这就是我们怎么样解释的对嗯
然后呢呃这里面呢我我再说一个概念吧
就是说呃工业界上有很多啊
这怎么说呢
嗯很很很多说法管它叫light bleeding啊
这块我不不建议这么用
因为这样的话和全局光照里面的那个所谓
color bleeding这概念就有点有点混淆这个意思
所以我更愿意管它叫light leaking
就是漏漏光嘛
这是挺正常的一件一件事情对吧
那那就是说呃这肯定是不好的对吧
那么另外一些不好的地方
那如果你的接收物咱们刚才才说嘛
接收物不是一个平面的话
它就会出现一些问题
那这这这些地方大家可以看到
有一些这些明显是rtfx这阴影断了对吧
然后呢呃切比雪夫不等式这边自己也有问题
咱们之前说过切比雪夫不等式
它只有在这个呃你你要查询的那个深度
他是在超过平均值的情况下才是准的
否则它不准对吧
然后这里也可能会造成问题
那么这些很多这些东西呢它都都会造成问题
那么这时候呃就是说人们就想了
我能不能避免vs s m的其中一个问题
那就是描述分布描述的不准啊
ok就是说就是说他解决不了什么什么
我就说moment shadow mapping
他他确实这样说吧
不是用来解决什么非平面接收物或者什么
它解决的问题很清楚
就是说我的vs s m里面
我描述一个分布深度的一个分布
我现在希望他描述的更准
我就想解决这么一个问题好吧
那么它怎么样去解决
它
引入了一个方法
就是使用更高阶的moments
moments是什么东西呢
中文的翻译叫做矩矩阵的矩啊
就是就是这一个字
它不是矩阵矩啊
就是就是高阶的矩去描述一个呃一个分布啊
这这是是什么鬼对吧
那那举是什么呢
这举这个概念啊
在在这个啊各种各样的数学资料里面
它定义的是非常非常五花八门的
就是是各种什么什么什么中心举什么杂七杂八
各种各样还是什么sin cosin的
是什么三角举啊
都非常多
但是呢嗯最简单的一系列的定义的举
它是怎么定义的呢
就是说哦我我我就我就直接可以用这个什么呢
就是用某一个数
某一个数
我去我去记录这个数
我记录这个数的平方
记录这个数的三次方
记录这个数的四次方
然后然后就一直这么这么记录下来就ok了
然后就是说我记录多少次方
那就是保留前多少阶的局啊
这么个意思好吧
那从这嗯
这个最最最直观的这么这么一个结论上来看
大家就可以看到哦
那v s s m做了件什么事对吧
那它其实就等于用了前两阶的局嘛
因为前两阶的局呢就是就是任何一个点嗯
就是shadow map上面任何一个像素
它对应的x和x的平方嘛
就是深度和深度的平方吗
还记得吧
而用这两个两个像在一块儿一倒腾
我就可以倒腾出来一个呃
virus就是它的分差对吗
就这个意思
那么我自然而然可以想象
那如果我多记录几阶呢
那它记录它的三次方
记录它的四次方
那我是不是对这个分布
对这个分布
它的它的这样一种一种估计就更准了呢
诶答案是的
然后但是这里呢我并不打算跟大家说
为什么是的好吧
因为这个过程实在是太复杂了
就是说我直接给大家到结论这里什么呢
就是说如果你保留前m阶的局
那么它嗯就是用这几阶的局啊
它就可以表示一个函数
一个什么函数
一个由一系列的这些接节约函数
堆起来的一个函数
并且它能表示几个台阶呢
它能表示二分之m个台阶啊
这么有意思啊
这直接讲着这个听起来有点难懂
但是呢很简单
看图就可以看出来了
我们要表示的什么呀
还记得吗
要么是pdf
要么是cdf对吧
就是说pdf的话就是正态分布
cdf呢就是一个就一直往上升的一个函数嘛
这两个呃一样的
最后我们肯定要用的是cdf吗
那这里面呢咱们就假设哦
这里我可以用前m结局去描述这个呃这个函数
一维的一个cdf
那这个cdf呢哎大家可以看到呃
哪一个是用前四阶局描述的函数啊
这个绿色的线啊
深绿的一条线
这这里一个光滑的深绿的线
然后说清诶我的鼠标真糟糕
我老是想着我鼠标在那啊
这里啊深绿的这么一条线
ok大家可以看哎
ok所以大家可以看
这里面很明显有两个台阶嘛对吧
有两个台阶
那这就意味着说哦这个函数我用四个呃
前四阶局就是z z平方
z3 次方
z4 次方诶
我就可以描述这个函数
也就是说给我这四个数啊
我立刻就可以恢复出这么一个cdf来
我有这cdf之后
那可就为所欲为了
对不对
那不是所有的这些这些查询
有百分之多少的东西比他比他大
这个cdf立刻就可以告诉我了对吧
那所以说嘛这就是呃这个举这么一个概念
说白了什么
刚才有同学说的太对了
就等于某种展开没问题
就跟什么泰勒展开啊
跟那些什么什么傅里叶展开都是一个道理的
就是说我就把它展开成前多少项
那我这前多少项
那我有可能不能恢复完整我之前的函数
但是我至少可以做到一
恢复成一个什么样的函数
那对于举来说就是这样的
我保证前呃呃保留前m阶局
我就可以描述一个由由m除以二个台阶
的一个函数
这是非常方便的一件事情对吧
那所以说呢诶呃嗯就是说呃我之前说过对吧
他这个作者就是crystal peters
他算是我朋友啊
然后他这个啊呃他做的这么一个呃呃工作
然后他发现正常情况下
咱们用四阶举购这些举
也就是说表示两个台阶已经足够了
然后呢他还这个唉跟pcf做了一个比较啊
pcf那得到的一个结果就是哎类似这样的
那它四阶的矩a挺相似的
非常不错
那p c f们就可以认为是挺准的了对吧
就是除了有一点噪声之外
那么大家会看到
但是像这种三阶三阶
你算什么一个半台阶嘛
就是说它会比这个呃四阶要差一些
比两阶的好一些啊
只能这么说啊
这么个意思好吧
然后呢哎他如果用前两节
那这就是virus shadow map嘛
对不对
然后呢大家可以看到
那这恢复出来的cdf和实际的是分布的cdf
就差了好多了对吧
诶那所以说嘛就是就是这么一个思路啊
那当然大家可以想象到
我用的举当然越多越好咯
越多就越准呢对吧
而我们想要什么呃
这这里有同学说的呃不完全正确哈
就是说展开了会过拟合
我们要的就是过拟合没问题吧
我要的是真实的分布呀对吧
他越真实越好呀
所以当然是越多越好
但是呢越多越好
他肯定他他不能无限多
多了都要存储的对吧
大家想一想
我每一个pixel我都要存储
原来是深度
然后用vs s m的话可以深度平方
那现在用举的话和三次方四次方我都要存的
是不是存储就往上要涨了
对不对
那呃但是没关系
就是说反正就是说呢
这个思路就跟v s s m就非常像了
我用motlemap无非就是增加了这么两项
然后呢
让他能够对这个分布有一个更精准的一个估计
那那vs sm做的是两部block search和pc f他都可以做
没有问题对吧
然后呢嗯哦这里顺便多说一句吧
就是说像这种数字挺多的
如果说不考虑精度的话
工业界有一个常见的做法叫做packing
and i'm packing
意思就是相当于是我有两个
比如说呃float 32位的两个数吧
我可以把它给表示成半精度的
就float 16星
然后把两个float 16给拼在一块
还作为一个float 32的channel去存
那不是省一半存储吗
哎这些都是一些常用技巧
甚至有一些划分到那个具体多少位的啊
这么个意思
然后就是说这块肯定是嗯有很多工作在做的啊
我就说一点
这这这什么呢
你如果这样做了之后
你就不能插值了哈
如果差值的话
那这个就没意义了吗
你两个16位的东西拼在一块
然后得到一个32位的
你又重新解释这32位的
某是某一个其他什么数
你在差值的时候把它当成一个32位的数
这差值中间值就全乱了
这么个意思啊
说一下
这就是工业界的一个做法
packing and packing啊
这两个小小的一个事情啊
然后呢呃就是说总结一下moon channel mapping
那当然他能得到非常好的结果
那咱们看vs s m
或者说他这里就管它直接叫vance shadomapping了
无所谓
vs m也是他
那么这里大家看到哦
这里light leaking非常严重的现象
对不对
然后但是在moon shadow map里面是非常非常干净的
他就说这边完全不会有shadow shadow呃
不是light leaking对吧
这个意思
那么问题咱们刚才说了
存储存储也许不是什么问题对吧
也许说我这啊我就这挤一挤对吧
就是总归总归我用刚才我说的这么这么些呃
什么方法
然后我可以节省一些存储
甚至存储都不是什么问题
但问题更多的是什么
这是我刚才没说的
给你前四结局
你怎么得到那么一个有两个台阶的函数哈
这个事情是一直没说的
对不对
而算这个东西是非常非常复杂的
然后这块来说
如果大家要看的话
就只能是从呃从peter的这个啊
呃ristopher的这个paper里面看了
好吧
然后然后就是这么一篇paper就叫moment channel mapping
然后这块的话嗯
而平常大家如果初学这块的话也用不着啊
而且确实paper写的也比较难懂一点
然后但是嗯就有用的东西还是挺多
我觉得工业界的朋友们倒是可以多了解一下
好吧
这是我个人建议了嗯
到此为止
今天的内容就讲完了好吧
然后欢迎同学们呃再问一些问题哦
我再停一下好吧
那同学问题的时候
我再简单说一下
下节课我打算这样
如果有时间的话
先讲这个所谓distance field呃
这个这个这个软件到底怎么回事啊
然后就是说为什么这个现在大家开始在用
我也不知道之后会不会用的更多啊
还是怎么着
这是一个
然后另外一个就是说
我们要开始进入到下一个话题了
我们要开始说环境光环境光照了好吧
阴影差不多了
嗯大概就是这么个意思啊
我来看看啊
目前我没见到有同学有什么其他问题
当然有可能是因为我卡了呗
哈哈那我就先这样吧
今天确实是因为sirh的事情嘛
挺开心
然后跟大家聊的东西也比较多
哈哈呃行啊
这个非常感谢大家理解
然后以及大家能够听我在这说这些事儿呃
行吧啊
然后希望大家这个能够跟我一样开心啊
这是好东西
大家分享啊
好心情
大家分享这个意思好嘞
那嗯咱们今天就到这儿啊
哦作业一的话
我刚刚说今天如果不行的话
就看明天吧
好吧好了
sdf的梯度对
打扫时看吧
好吧行吧
感谢同学们
我下播了哈啊给同学们赶紧吃饭吧
啊拜拜